hey friends welcome back to the channel
this is a little clip from my
conversation with logan yuri the
best-selling author of the book how to
not die alone logan is also a behavioral
scientist and relationship therapist and
in this little clip we are talking about
how to find a love on dating apps what
are the things that we can do when we're
on dating apps when we're doing online
dating to increase the chances that
we're going to match with that special
someone and that we will then make
things work with that special someone a
few months ago i was i was i was going
on a few dates and we were kind of
chatting a bit by whatsapp messages
afterwards
and uh obviously i turned to some of my
female friends to help me respond to
some of these messages uh as as one does
um
and one of the points that i of a
feedback that i got from some people and
this was not everyone but but some
people was that
i was coming across as too keen and my
response rate was too fast and
she said that thing and she asked you a
question and then you
responded to it but then you like overly
elaborated on that response which
signals to her
that
you have nothing better to do with your
time that you're begging for her
attention she you know in the dating
stage she wants to feel as if she's
doing some of the work therefore you
need to tone the hell down your response
time and kind of be less like a beggy
about like the way you're responding to
her
uh this was some of my female friends
there were other female friends that
were like that's completely terrible
advice you're just having a normal
conversation like screw all of that
what's the what's the solution here
okay i am giggling and covering my face
because this is such a hot topic that i
could talk about for hours everything
you're saying i could talk about for
hours but
i feel honored to get the chance to bust
some myths yes so remember right i work
with people one-on-one i have the
anecdotes i have the stories i also work
at hinge which means i have access to
millions of data points around how this
stuff works we did this fascinating
research on the topic of responsiveness
and what we found is that if somebody
messages you and you respond within the
hour you have a much greater chance of
having a long conversation and even
going on a date
and so all of this nonsense around play
games match how many hours she waited to
respond and then you do the same
none of that
helps you get into a relationship with
somebody who's a good communicator who
talks authentically who is somebody who
you can be yourself with all of that is
a way to just maximize a game and you're
not trying to play a game or win a game
you're trying to find a long-term
relationship and so what i would say is
remember
you are talking to a bunch of people she
is talking to a bunch of people right
it's a noisy bar with a lot of
conversations
one of the best ways to stand out is to
just engage in a conversation with her
and try to make it as synchronous so
talking at the same time as possible and
so the data on this is very clear
responsiveness on a dating app
is a useful strategy because it helps
you get into the conversation and stand
out and one thing that you can do
strategically is pretty early on say
something like you know i'm more into
texting can we transition to text and
something about getting from the busy
dating app inbox to the more personal um
texting or snapchat inbox is that now
you're in the place where her friends
are and you can help stand out and so
generally in that place i would say you
want to be playful and you want to play
but you don't want to play games i
remember a few
probably probably earlier this year um
i was on one of these apps this was on
mismatch actually um
that i interviewed the founder of on
this podcast in episode number two if
anyone wants to check it out um
there was a girl whose profiler came
across
who i wasn't like like like i wasn't
massively sold on the profile i was just
like um kind of lukewarm towards it but
one of the prompts that she said she's
she said like you know what's one fact
about me that will surprise you or
something like that and she said i reply
ridiculously fast to messages i was like
oh okay and then i commented on that as
being like just testing or something
something something like that and she
replied within like 10 seconds and we
ended up going on a date and actually
having a great time and like
you know the spark wasn't there and and
and all this and that but like we
actually had a great conversation
through the app
went on the date and i was like wow
this person really stands out by
actually being quick at responding to
messages because otherwise it's like you
send a message you wait 18 hours nothing
happens you know et cetera et cetera
like it was such a breath of fresh air
um and i just never
i guess i guess in my head because as a
as a guy in this scenario i think guys
are more sensitive to the a girl will be
turned off if you come across as too
keen i i i didn't quite
sort of put two and two together and
think you know maybe if i were quicker
at responding people would would vibe
with me a bit better
i want to make a metapoint because i
think
a lot of what you're bringing to me as
questions are things that are like
there's an old wives tale or there's
general cultural wisdom that you should
do x and many of my answers are no i
would advise doing y and so i think we
could go through all of those different
ones but i just want to make this as a
general point which is that if you were
to start a youtube channel and all you
did was study the most popular youtube
channels you might just end up creating
a copy of the most popular people done
with worse lighting worse audio
equipment worst guest and you are less
good at interviewing right you're just
doing a copy of something else and you
blend into the background
maybe you want to do something different
maybe you want to innovate maybe you
want to stand out
and i think that sometimes when we're
looking at so many profiles doing
something surprising creating that hook
showing your individuality is the best
possible thing that you can do because
if you see 10 dead fish pictures in a
row and then you see a guy who says i
spend most of my day on the computer
because that is my job but at night i'd
love to play a board game with you that
is different and so for her you know
you're talking about men don't want to
seem like they are too available so they
shouldn't respond quickly well women
also want to don't want to seem like
they're too needy so in writing that
she's really standing out and i think
it's it's not
that there are no rules but i think in
general these rules make us focus on the
wrong thing when the things that we
should be focusing on are be the best
person you can be
invest in your communication skills
learn how to talk about hard topics like
sex and conflict treat the other person
well and when you know that you're not
interested in somebody break up with
them in a kind respectful and firm way
and move on i think if we worked on
those foundational skills of human
connection and less time on well how
long did she spend to respond to this
message and do i seem needy i i think
that that's investing the wrong energy
in the wrong place hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day